hey guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry today
we're checking out the second trailer
for the gift just so you know we're
doing this for you guys
cuz the studios i made this what let us
monetize this video so this is strictly
for you guys i'm taking time out of my
day to film edit these videos upload
them tag them and annotate them yet
i'm not gonna make a penny off this
video wow that is a crime it's a crime I
work hard at watching other people's
content and commenting on and commenting
on my subconscious instinct feelings in
2006 a Nebraska man killed his former
teacher for failing him after cheating
on a test
18 years earlier in 2009 a nurse was
accused of administering a fatal dose of
a painkiller to a patient the nurse
believed the patient had stolen a
high-school boyfriend in 20 years before
Wow
in 2013 a 68 year old man drove to the
home of a former classmate who like
bullied him fifty years earlier
dead the real and bygones ever really be
bygones
excuse me we went to school together
sorry athlean place here gordon mosley
Gordo Gordo
honey Gordon when I went to school
together look very long time ago I
believe the bad things from the past
they can be a gift guys hard I think he
wants to hurt us for something that
happened
you're done with the past
the past is not he's pretty cool
I saw another trailer that was way
longer but this one actually hooked me
pretty well I almost feels like a like a
teaser track
yeah it does and I'm okay with just that
yeah I know that's cool like it's it
actually has very ominous I think it
better almost better communicates the
ominous Ness
yeah cuz I didn't I didn't quite grasp
like the intensity of the situation but
you know it's cool that they started off
like with what looks like their facts
I'm not sure if statistic yeah that is a
just a clever plot are you paying for
your sins that you committed ages ago
yeah something you might not even
remember somebody else's yeah entire
portions of their personality on top of
that could have been you and I cuz I was
a dick to you maybe this is still
lovable I was lovable when we were alone
it was most people were ah like most
people were kind of a dick in public the
Bennis like one-on-one everyone's cool
well you see Jerry good lesson I get
what's happening now you're just like
this guy i'm joel edgerton your plan is
befriend everyone that way no one
suspects you as the killers right genius
and then when the channels like edit
speak I'm gonna kill you and get even
worse oh dude respect
thanks man respect I you know if there's
one person that could kill me I would
want it to be you Thanks did you know
joel edgerton wrote and directed this I
did yeah I was very surprised the first
time I saw the show I was like wow this
does look good I mean before I was like
Jason Bateman in this role I don't know
but I could see Jason Bateman totally as
like a dude who was a bully
Jason Bateman yes sarcastic [ __ ] who
you know you know guy who's like now
he's like playing Jason Bateman regular
sort of put-upon nice guy Jason Bateman
who used to be [ __ ] Jason Peyton yeah
yeah it's like both of those are one
character now and Rebecca Hall she's a
good actress and joel edgerton is really
good I
[ __ ] love joel edgerton anything he
does I'm always impressed so seeing him
and this it's it's an interesting kind
of it might be his debut I don't know if
he's done anything before well I haven't
seen anything well this is like the
first feature of his it's probably I
really being promoted you know so I'm
interested just for that reason alone to
see how he handles this and bloom house
you know obviously allows their
directors and writers to have their
creative freedom it's gonna be
interesting to see like what is a
well-known studio do for a first time
like writer director who's an actor
transitioning into this well yeah and
I'm surprised you know cuz their thing
is taking people who have been sort of
bucked by the system so I wonder if this
is a project he's been trying to get
made for years and years and years
because they're they've you know Jason
Blum has even said like you know we're
not the place for first-timers like go
out and try it in the regular you know
cinema landscape before coming to us so
I wonder if this is like a passion
project for Joel Edgerton that just no
one would take until me yeah I mean I
bet him a green a star in this and the
antagonist role probably helped get this
movie made I mean we could speculate
about the business aspect all we want
good I mean it's different material than
what other people yeah
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out reasons to Gerry and
Dan gasps Stubbs on this channel and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope because if we
get enough followers we can get even
more prominent Tom Thank You Wes pie
peas Gillespie please give me a shout
out please Tom Glen so polite this is
what happened with the last person I
gave a shout out to you didn't put down
anything interesting for us to work off
of for this shout out then you see the
shout out if you want solid comedy you
have got to provide something
interesting that we can rip off of
that's like improv is that give us a
suggestion a suggestion you know give us
a location Disneyland
that's always the [ __ ] location and
improv show isn't it better McDonald
Eldar ball yeah I know
give us a John Rowe Worcester horror
well I mean John
and then some [ __ ] is in the
audience there's like comedy
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] thanks man
thanks for your vote of confidence
thanks Tom Gillespie that's the kind of
[ __ ] suggestions you give no typical
what everyone suggests and then after
you suggest after you go Wooster and you
go huh I'm so funny cuz I suggested
listener along audience members I just
like this was bookended by pleases so
polite then I forgive you for your
stupid cuz it give me a shout-out please